well-truth social is very rapidly
heading towards bankruptcy and I
actually do like this but not because I
necessarily want to see it fail but
because it does confirm that the demand
that the right claims is there for some
completely unfettered free speech
platform for the right to be allowed to
say what they want really isn't there
there really isn't the demand for it so
let's back up a little bit truth social
is this right-wing social media platform
it's Donald Trump's social media
platform to some degree and the idea of
Truth social was all of the conservative
voices being censored on Twitter and
elsewhere you're going to be able to go
to truth social and you will be free to
say whatever you want everyone can say
whatever they want on Truth social turns
out number one
wasn't actually the case lots of people
getting banned on Truth social for
talking about the January 6 committee
hearings or for all bunch of different
things so it turns out it wasn't really
this free speech platform they claim it
would be secondly turns out it wasn't
really a platform too many people were
interested in and the latest sort of
nail in the coffin is that investors are
pulling almost 140 million dollars from
the company that is planning to merge
with Trump's truth social The Business
Insider article writes the deadline for
digital world to acquire Trump's truth
social past on September 20th investors
are walking away from planned
commitments of 140 million dollars
Reuters reports that Sabi management
investors bowed out taking away 100
million dollars this is going to likely
be the demise of Truth social and of
course as far as these investors go the
fact that they were going to invest in
the first Place shows that they're not
necessarily the most brilliant investors
many of the businesses that Trump is a
part of end up going under and investors
lose money Trump tries to run away with
the cash and it's a complete and total
disaster but I think the most important
the reason I love this is that they love
to say the entire right and you know
they claim sometimes they'll claim the
right is 225 million people Trump
recently said
75 million people voted for him
and that there's probably another 150
million trumpists as well the numbers
don't even make sense it's absurd
numbers if you look at how many adults
there are in the U.S makes no sense
whatsoever but their story is there's
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
of us we are being silenced on Twitter
and everywhere else and we really want a
platform where we can say what we want
and say what we believe and it's going
to be great and it's going to be
profitable and it's going to explode
they create truth social
and it just kind of goes nowhere and
what I love is that truth social is
failing in the marketplace of ideas
nobody's censoring truth social
nobody's shutting it down but slowly but
surely people don't care
they don't really have users and it just
declines and declines and declines and
it looks like ultimately it's going to
end up going under completely it will of
course be blamed on radical leftists
global-ish whatever but the reason it's
failing is because it's terrible and
it's even sort of like a Twitter clone
if you look at the platform the buttons
the read the retruth and all the entire
design and user interface it's basically
a Twitter clone and so if your belief is
Twitter on a technical level is fine but
it needs to be free from censorship of
conservatives then by definition truth
social should be doing really well it's
not it's not doing well and it's going
to go under and I absolutely love it